und jetzt das heute journal
guten Abend am 24 februar vor genau neun
Monaten begann Russland seinen Überfall
auf die gesamte Ukraine seit neun
Monaten also wehren sich die Ukraine mit
Erfolg das hatten ihnen viele ja so
nicht zugetraut am allerwenigsten wohl
Vladimir Putin er und seine Generäle
Versuchung es nun mit Zermürbung der
Zivilbevölkerung aber auch das hat
bisher nicht die gewünschte Wirkung den
Widerstand der Ukrainer zu brechen nach
Angaben der Regierung ist das gelungen
das gesamt ukrainische Stromnetz sowie
der instand zu setzen das Strom
überhaupt wieder fließen kann was aber
leider nicht heißt dass er auch wieder
in alle Haushalte fließt noch ist etwa
jeder zweite ohne Elektrizität was das
im Alltag bedeutet berichtete
unterwegs durch den Süden der Ukraine in
Odessa sind die Straßen wieder
stockdunkel hier ist der Strom fast
komplett ausgefallen die ukrainischen
techniktrupps sind zwar erfahren darin
zerstörte Infrastruktur schnell wieder
herzurichten Russland macht diese
Einrichtungen durch ständige Attacken
aber langsam mürbe sie wurden
jetzt haben wir die Stromversorgung an
den wichtigsten Einrichtungen im ganzen
Land wiederhergestellt und wir werden
nach und nach mehr Energie produzieren
ja diese erste Reparatur der
beschossenen Energieversorgung ist aber
nicht sehr belastbar bereits am
Nachmittag waren 50% der Stromkunden
schon wieder vom Netz auch in odesstern
mussten Friseure entscheiden der Handy
leuchten die Haare ihre Kunden schneiden
auf den Straßen versuchten
Geschäftsleute ihre Notstromaggregate zu
starten
nicht jeder hatte so viel Glück wie der
Friseur
Generatoren sind nicht dafür gemacht
nonstop zu laufen sie brauchen Pausen
außerdem verstopfen die Filter denn die
Qualität des Treibstoffs ist viel
schlechter als früher
dieses Café kann sich keinen Generator
leisten es ist nur so lange offen wie
die Getränke in der Thermoskanne Reichen
und die Batterien die Lampen leuchten
lassen mehr denn je lernt die Ukraine zu
improvisieren
derweil streiten sich die Europäer über
ihren gemeinsamen europäischen gasdecke
die EU-Kommission hatte ja vorgeschlagen
für den Gaseinkauf einer Preisobergrenze
zu setzen den einen ist sie allerdings
zu hoch Gas sei dann immer noch viel zu
teuer andere darunter Deutschland sind
von der ganzen Idee nicht überzeugt bei
einem Treffen heute in Brüssel ging es
dann ziemlich hoch her berichtet Florian
neuer
Josef siekeler weiß schon am Morgen dass
das heute wieder nichts wird wie in den
Sondersitzungen zuvor unsere beginnt der
aktuelle Ratsvorsitzende aus Tschechien
den Tag mit einer kleinen Drohung
[Musik]
ich bin bereit so viele Sondersitzungen
einzuberufen wie nötig damit wir endlich
einen Kompromiss finden
Europa hat sich hoffnungslos verhakt im
Streit um den gaspreisdeckel also einen
Höchstpreis auf Gas das Europa anderswo
einkauft damit sollen kreisspitzen wie
im August vermieden werden die
EU-Kommission hatte am Dienstag an den
Deckel von 275 Euro pro Megawattstunde
vorgeschlagen allerdings unter so vielen
Bedingungen dass dieser Deckel selbst im
August nicht gegriffen hätte ein
Vorschlag der beide Lager erzürnt Gegner
wie Deutschland die starre Preisgrenzen
ablehnen und preisdeckel-fans wie Polen
den in dieser Plan nicht reicht
das ist doch ein Witz nach so vielen
Verhandlungen und Vorschlägen von den
Mitgliedstaaten
dann habe ich kein Angebot mehr wenn ich
kein Angebot mehr habe habe ich auch
kein Gas mehr am Ende wie erwartet
wieder keine Einigung und ein
tschechischer Minister der verzweifelt
positive Nachrichten sucht we have the
clarity wir haben nun die Klarheit dass
wir in den nächsten Tagen hart arbeiten
wollen um eine Einigung zu erreichen
immerhin der Termin für die nächste
Sondersitzung steht bereits in drei
Wochen
der Menschenrechtsrat der Vereinten
Nationen hat heute eine Untersuchung der
Menschenrechtslage in Iran beschlossen
das mag zunächst nach Papiertiger
klingen natürlich wird man an Regime das
Krieg gegen die eigene Bevölkerung führt
davon nicht mit Beschlüssen und
Verurteilungen abhalten können und
trotzdem das ist heute dafür so große
Zustimmung gab das war bemerkenswert und
ist für Teheran ein diplomatischer
Schlag angeregt hatten die Resolution
Deutschland und Island mehr Hintergründe
dazu von
im kurdischen Westiran machen bewaffnete
Regimetruppen Jagd auf protestierend
kurdische Städte werden inzwischen von
Militäreinheiten weitgehend abgeriegelt
in Teheran besichtigt der Präsident der
Wahl eine U-Bahn-Baustelle als wäre
nichts geschehen und seine Schergen
nennen die brutale Polizeigewalt zynisch
eine Lappalie
vielleicht gab es da die eine oder
andere Überreaktion unserer Polizei aber
sowas passiert halt
gemeint ist das hier Schüsse ins Gesicht
mehr als 300 Tote 14.000 Bürger
verhaftet darunter Kinder der
Menschenrechtsrat der Vereinten Nationen
kritisierte das iranische Vorgehen heute
scharf
ich rufe die iranischen Behörden auf
jede Gewalt gegen friedliche
protestierendes sofort einzustellen
auf Antrag Deutschlands und Islands
wurde die Einsetzung einer
Untersuchungskommission beschlossen um
Beweise für eine mögliche
Strafverfolgung der Täter zusammen
wir haben Iran wiederholt aufgefordert
das brutale Vorgehen zu stoppen das Blut
vergießen die willkürlichen Tötungen
Massenverhaftungen Todesstrafen die
Antwort war stets mehr Gewalt
die Vertreterin alle Vorwürfe zurück sie
kritisierte Deutschland scharf den so
wirklich selbst ernannten Weltmeister
der Menschenrechte für polit motivierte
Initiativen die zu nichts führten
vor dem berüchtigten eving-gefängnis in
Tehran warten unterdessen täglich
Angehörige verzweifelt auf ein
Lebenszeichen von den vielen willkürlich
verhafteten
mit dem Thema Menschenrechte geht es bei
dir jetzt auch noch mal weiter Heinz
Russland schränkt die rechte sexueller
Minderheiten weiter ein positive
Darstellungen etwa von lesbischer und
schwuler Liebe sollen mit einer
Geldstrafe geerntet werden besagt ein
Gesetz dass die staatsuma verabschiedet
hat es muss noch von der zweiten
Parlamentskammer und von Präsident Putin
gebilligt werden was aber als Formsache
gilt
nach Deutschland das Bundeskriminalamt
hat in einer Statistik zur
partnerschaftsgewalt für das vergangene
Jahr rund 143.600
Opfer registriert 80% sind Frauen die
Fallzahlen liegen etwas unter denen von
2020 über einen Fünfjahreszeitraum
gesehen gibt es allerdings einen Anstieg
und es wird von einer hohen Dunkelziffer
ausgegangen
Bundesgesundheitsminister Lauterbach hat
in der corona-lage vor zu früher
Sorglosigkeit gewarnt auch um ältere und
vorerkrankte Menschen zu schützen
Lauterbach sagte im Bundestag man habe
hier noch ein paar Monate in denen es
schwerer sein werde es gebe aber
Hinweise auf eine Entschärfung der
Situation das Virus Scheine bei seiner
Weiterverbreitung in eine Sackgasse
geraten zu sein in der nur noch geringe
Veränderungen möglich sein noch
ansteckender zu werden und noch kurz zu
den Wetteraussichten morgen wird es in
einem breiten Streifen von
Schleswig-Holstein bis zum Bodensee
häufig regnen westlich und östlich davon
bleibt es meist trocken die Temperatur
steigt auf 5 bis 12 Grad am Wochenende
gibt es ruhiges Wetter mit teils Sonne
teils
erst wieder am Montag im Nordwesten
das war es auch schon von uns in dieser
Halbzeitpause und um 0 Uhr gibt es dann
unser heute schon ein Update mit
Christopher Wehrmann und uns morgen
wieder auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]